foreign
I want to do a quick exercise close your
eyes
I want you to picture your best friend
think about what specifically you love
about them
what trait makes them them
now open your eyes
I don't know what each of you came up
with but I'm pretty sure I know what you
didn't come up with
I'm pretty sure none of you thought what
makes Jim Jim is the fact that he's six
foot two and a redhead
I'm guessing you chose their inner
qualities their sense of humor their
generosity their intelligence qualities
they would have no matter what they
looked like
there's one more quality I'm pretty sure
you didn't choose
their race
of all the things you could list about
somebody their race is just about the
least interesting you can name right
down there with height and hair color
sure race can be good source material
for jokes at a comedy club but in the
real world a person's race doesn't tell
you whether they're kind or selfish
whether their beliefs are right or wrong
whether they'll become your best friend
or your worst enemy
but over the past 10 years our societies
have become more and more fixated on
racial identity
we've all been invited to reflect on our
inner whiteness or inner Blackness as if
these racial Essences Define Who We Are
meanwhile American society has
experienced the greatest crisis in race
relations in a generation
Gallup has been asking Americans how
they feel about race relations and this
chart is the result
so as you can see between 2001 and 2013
most Americans felt good about race
relations then both lines take a
nosedive
it's no exaggeration to call this one of
the greatest crises of our time
and clearly we need new ways of thinking
about race if we're going to reverse
this trend
so today I'm going to offer an old idea
but it's an idea that's been widely
misunderstood
you've probably heard it before it's
called color blindness
what do I mean by colorblindness after
all we all see race we can't help it
and what's more race can influence how
we're treated and how we treat other
people so in that sense nobody is truly
colorblind
but to interpret the word colorblind so
literally is to misunderstand it
colorblind is a word like warm-hearted
it uses a physical metaphor to capture
an abstract idea
to call someone warm-hearted isn't to
talk about the temperature of their
heart but about the kindness of their
soul
and similarly to advocate for color
blindness is not to pretend you don't
notice race
it's to support a principle
that we should try our best to treat
people without regard to race both in
our personal lives and in our public
policy
and you might be thinking what's so
controversial about that
well the fact is the philosophy of
colorblindness is under attack
critics say that it's naive
or that we're not yet ready for it as a
society or even that it's white
supremacy in disguise
and many people agree with these
feelings for example a few years ago a
young adult fantasy author came under
pressure to Halt the release of her new
book why
because the marketing blurb for the book
went like this
in a world where the princess is the
monster oppression is blind to skin
color and good and evil exist in Shades
of Gray
now that one sentence clause about
oppression being blind to skin color
describing a fantasy world mind you was
enough to provoke an online backlash
now part of this reaction to color
blindness is actually a fault of its
advocates
people will say things like I don't see
color as a way of expressing support for
colorblindness
but this phrase is guaranteed to produce
confusion because you do see color right
I think we should all get rid of this
phrase and replace it with what we
really mean to say which is I try to
treat people without regard to race
now that said most of the pushback to
colorblindness comes from critics who
misrepresent it as somehow a
conservative idea
now this could not be further from the
truth
the philosophy of colorblindness does
not come from conservatives it actually
comes from the radical wing of the
anti-slavery movement in the 19th
century
the earliest mentions of colorblindness
come from Wendell Phillips who was the
president of the American anti-slavery
society and a man whose nickname was
abolition's golden trumpet
he believed an immediate full equality
for black Americans and in 1865 he
called for the creation of a quote
government colorblind by which he meant
the permanent end of all laws that
mentioned race
what about the other critiques of
colorblindness
wouldn't colorblindness render us unable
to fight racism wouldn't it mean getting
rid of policies like affirmative action
that benefit people of color
I believe that eliminating race-based
policies does not equal eliminating
policies meant to reduce inequality
it simply means that those policies
should be executed on the basis of class
instead of race
why class over race
I'll give two reasons
first because class is almost always a
better proxy for True disadvantage than
race
imagine we picked 10 Americans at random
and our task is to sort them from least
privileged on one end to most privileged
on the other
now there's no direct measure of
privilege so we have to choose a proxy
measure
my claim here is that lining them up by
income or wealth
would get us closer to achieving that
task than simply lining people up by
race that's what I mean when I say that
class is usually a better proxy for
disadvantage than race
and the second reason is that
class-based policies tend to be more
popular and less controversial because
they don't penalize anyone for immutable
biological traits
think of policies like need-based
financial aid or the Earned Income Tax
Credit
these are policies that address
inequality without anyone having to feel
the sting of racial discrimination
I want to give you an example of a
disastrous race-based policy it was
called the restaurant revitalization
fund
over seventy thousand restaurants closed
in 2020 due to the pandemic and this
fund allocated 29 billion dollars to
help these restaurants but for the first
three weeks of the program only people
of color women and Veterans could apply
so soon after it began white male
restaurant owners sued alleging
discrimination a judge ruled in their
favor and the program was stopped but by
that time two-thirds of the money was
already gone
and it wasn't just white men that got
discriminated against in this policy
around 3 000 women and people of color
were promised money before the judge
stopped the program and then unpromised
that money just after
and the remaining 10 billion then went
to white men who had initially been put
at the back of the line
so the net result of this policy was a
double dose of discrimination initially
thousands of white men were
discriminated against and then thousands
of women and people of color were
discriminated against
and it's a virtual guarantee that there
are people out there who lost their
restaurant in both of those camps
because they were the wrong skin color
can anyone really argue that a
colorblind program
wouldn't have produced better results
for everybody
so I just gave an example of a
disastrous race-based policy now I want
to give you an example of a colorblind
policy that has worked quite well
America has been struggling with the
issue of racial bias and policing for a
very long time
and a solution to one aspect of this
problem is to issue tickets using
traffic cameras instead of human beings
cops can be racially biased consciously
or not but traffic cameras red light
cameras and speeding cameras can't
so you would think anyone interested in
reducing racial bias in policing
would support these traffic cameras but
you'd be wrong
some have opposed them on the grounds
that they don't yield statistically
equal ticketing rates by race and they
remain illegal in many U.S states
so here's an example where the
philosophy of colorblindness cuts
through confusion Like a Knife
if we're Guided by color blindness our
goal should be to eliminate bias from
systems that affect people's lives
wherever possible not to manufacture
statistically equal outcomes by any
means necessary
so my talk has been focused on America
but my message is really for any key
decision maker at any institution
anywhere in the world
if you care about fighting racism
Embrace colorblindness
support class-based policies
create colorblind processes in your own
world if you're a professor grade your
students papers blind to their names
think creatively about how to apply
color blindness to your life
colorblindness is the best principle by
which to govern a multi-racial
multi-ethnic democracy
it's the best way to lower the
temperature of tribal conflict in the
long run
and if we wait for the moment when
Society is ready for it
we'll be waiting forever
thank you
thank you for this you know Melody
Hobson came to Ted a few years ago and
she had a very different message for her
she said
be color Brave not colorblind her
argument was that
being colorblind is dangerous because
it's effectively ignoring the problem
what would you want to say to her yeah
so I mean I one thing I would say is
like I said colorblindness as a
philosophy that that is the goal that's
an idea that comes from the anti-slavery
movement right that's not an example of
ignoring the problem that's an example
of having the best philosophy with which
to address the problem in my view but
could you argue that that dealt with one
part of the problem but in today's world
there are still many situations where
it's not enough so to take take the
story of so here's a an orchestra right
an orchestra and it's largely white
um and that doesn't feel right so they
Institute a policy of colorblindness
where you know there can't be any racial
discrimination because new musicians are
auditioned behind the screen does
colorblind so so far so good and maybe
that helps but maybe the actual
situation is that
the minority kids in that area just
don't have access to instruments it's
just harder for them ever to get the
kind of training and stuff they need and
that the orchestra needs to be taking a
lead to bring people through so that
there are people in that Orchestra who
can Inspire the kids and so forth
yeah so I would I would propose a
different so if I were leading that
Orchestra what I would do is I say
let's continue to audition everyone
behind the veil be colorblind uh in that
sense and then let's separately invest
in the community so that we can get kids
instruments when they're young and then
judge them by a colorblind standard when
they come to audition see if you if you
rig it at this level then you're just
changing the bar by which you would
measure progress to begin with right so
I think that is a kind of an artificial
solution whereas we we want to maintain
colorblind standards but actually
address the root causes of the problem
common um you're an incredibly powerful
voice on this issue and I really thank
you for the courage to come here make
make this case and thank you good luck
with the book Thank you Ted coming here
thank you